Sathya Narayanan: Let me pause here. Any questions on anything I said? Did I share too… you know, did I present too much? Did I go too fast?
Sathya Narayanan: Okay, I see some thumbs up. We are going to play with it, and you can come back and ask questions, so I'm not, you know, don't… if something's not clear, you're going to get your hands dirty, and you can come back and ask questions. Jeff, I'm sorry, you were going to say something, yeah.
Jeff D'Andria: I had a question, I'm curious, because this, this idea of the niche.
Jeff D'Andria: Seems really important, that's why we're kicking it off this way, but for a student that may be out there and is maybe asking.
Jeff D'Andria: like, what… sorry, I'm still not understanding how this is gonna… why is this important versus me just applying to jobs, because there's a bunch that maybe want software engineers or computer science students. Why is my niche important in that?
Sathya Narayanan: They're so similar.
Jeff D'Andria: You know, I just think it's important.
Sathya Narayanan: That's a good question, yeah, that's a good question. Yeah, that's fair. I'll respond to it in two ways.
Sathya Narayanan: One… actually, I'll probably say the second one first.
Sathya Narayanan: Please…
Sathya Narayanan: be committed to this idea, at least for, like, a week or… like, two weeks, I would say, and you are really going to see the value of it. When you kind of start defining your niche, the value is going to be more obvious than the answer I'm going to give. I'm going to give you an answer, but I do want to…
Sathya Narayanan: ask for your trust that this is important. Take, you know, trust us and kind of try it, right? Because nothing I say in 3-5 minutes will convince you as when you see it yourself, right? So just kind of keep that in mind. With that, the answer is.
Sathya Narayanan: Think about… I don't know, like, you know, it helps you define your targets better.
Sathya Narayanan: Right? You're… you're… let's say you're target shooting.
Sathya Narayanan: Not shooting is a bad thing, like, I'm just using it as an analogy. If you go into a forest or something and go like this, you'll probably hit a bunch of things, but you're not going to shoot the thing that you want, right? Versus, you want to define the target that you want to, kind of.
Sathya Narayanan: aim at, right? The niche is that, right? There is something I am good at, there is something the market wants.
Sathya Narayanan: Here is the overlap.
Sathya Narayanan: Right? This overlap means I should apply to these kind of jobs and these kind of industries, with this kind of a message, and this is how my resume should look. Increases your chances of
Sathya Narayanan: Hitting the target.
Sathya Narayanan: Right? Versus, kind of… and again, to some extent, the numbers are still good. You do want to, kind of.
Sathya Narayanan: Shoot everywhere a little bit, too.
Sathya Narayanan: the current market, when the entry-level jobs are becoming more tricky and difficult, the numbers game is not going to work. When there's a whole bunch of jobs, and people are all looking to hire, like, when it is…
Sathya Narayanan: bias or sellers, depending on if the job search
Sathya Narayanan: people have a higher hand because companies are really scrambling, which was how things were 5 years ago, right? Pre-COVID, the demand, particularly for computer science, was a lot higher than the people available. Then you can just kind of, like, send your resume out, and you'll get, like, multiple interviews.
Sathya Narayanan: When the market is kind of different, you need to be a lot more strategic with your, with your… So that's the answer, right? That's the answer to the question, but again, try it, and then you will start seeing its value, and you can make adjustments as you go along.
Jeff D'Andria: Perfect, yeah. I just wanted to make sure, and I 100% agree, and anytime I've helped someone in the last year or so, and they're not getting a lot of hits, this is the gear down that we go to, is we say, stop spraying and praying, what's your niche?
Sathya Narayanan: That's where.
Jeff D'Andria: You want to get your shots on goal. It's like a bullseye, like a tar… you're gonna slowly get closer to the bullseye, so that's it.
Sathya Narayanan: You can still do the spraying also, right? Spend a half an hour every day just sending everywhere. I think that's fine too. You never know, like, none of us know the future, like, you may get lucky, that might get the best job offer through that way. But this has better chances of success.